hier soir à la nuit tombée un jeune
garçon de 10 ans a été tué par balle
parce qu'il faisait trop de bruit avec
ses camarades cela s'est passé dans la
cité des 4000
un ensemble qui abrite des travailleurs
immigrés en grande partie on ne sait
toujours pas qui a tiré sur le petit
toufik le coup est parti d'une fenêtre
et l'enfant est mort l'enquète de claude
crespo et de bruno le dreff toufik 10
ans jouer ici à l'endroit où son grand
frère se trouve quand il a été
mortellement blessée d'une balle de 22
long rifle qu'il a été ni en pleine
poitrine d'une balle tirée d'une de ses
fenêtres mais laquelle
il y en a des centaines c'était soir de
ramadhan le dernier avec le coucher du
soleil le début des réjouissances
toufik les trois ou quatre copains
s'amuse au pied de l'immeuble
ils font sauter des pétards il est 20h30
une personne qu'on a toujours pas
retrouvé excédé par le bruit tire qu'un
cheveu la partie car
9 une bouteille qui est tombé attendait
la glace tout le monde là elles n'ont
donc elle venait de là ou alors après
qu'est ce qui s'est passé après on a
passé un petit peu on a tiré de mètres
carrés un couteau et l'a reçue par mon
crash team fait montre combien le crous
et la balle a été entendu sous la
terrasse et puis on a vu il faiblissait
et de l'année un peu partout parce que
la mli dans la pierre laba s'appliquait
texte appelait sa mère
et puis son frère est venu il est appelé
la police toufik est mort ici sur cette
pierre dans l'entrée de son immeuble
un petit garçon de 10 ans sans histoire
celui qui a visé monfils est une grande
personne je pense pourquoi pensez-vous
ça parce que c'est quelqu'un qui attrape
une mitraillette groupe personne et
c'est quelqu'un qui habite à la
courneuve dans les bals immeuble oui
dans l'immeuble je ne sais pas mais je
sais que la personne habite la courneuve
il ya soirée volant il est beaucoup de
bruit ici ce qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
bruit sur tellement fière non pas
tellement je voudrais qu un trouble
l'assassin de mon fils il s'est tu
cette cité de la courneuve s'est senti
mal fréquenté ya beaucoup de signes
habitable fait que la cité des 4000
un nom qui lui vient du nombre de
logements construite en 1963 pour les
rapatriés d'afrique du nord par l'office
hlm de la ville de paris on appelait ça
la construction tunnel typiquement
années 60 lui bâtiment de 50 mètres de
haut sur 200 m de long conçu pour dix
mille habitants
aujourd'hui ils sont quinze mille dont
3900 d'origine étrangère à 6 ans passés
la cité des 4000 est avec les minguettes
de lyon un des 16 quartiers choisis par
la commission du buzz ou pour être
réhabilité en priorité